We're on problem 53.
Which table below correctly
describes the points of the
exponential function f of
x is equal to 3 to the
minus x minus 2?
They all input the same x-values
as far as I can tell.
Yeah, they all input
the same x-values.
So let's just figure out
which choice works.
So if we take f of minus
2, that's the first
one they give us.
f of minus 2, that is equal
to 3 to the minus x.
Well, x is now minus 2, so
minus minus 2 minus 2.
So what's minus minus 2?
Well, that's the same thing as
3 squared minus 2, so that is
equal to 9 minus 2
is equal to 7.
Did I get that right?
Do you see any of
these choices?
Well, only one of them
has that. f of minus
2 is equal to 7.
That's not right.
Well, here when x is minus
2, f of x is equal
to 7, choice D.
We could have just evaluated the
other ones and we probably
would have agreed with all
of these numbers as well.
Well, that was a lot of copying
and pasting for a
fairly straightforward
problem.
Next problem.
I already had it there
waiting for us.
log base 6 of 40.
So, in general, and just
inspecting it, I think they
just want you to figure out
how do you figure out a
logarithm of any arbitrary base
of some number if you
only have a log base 10
function, which tends to be
the case in your calculator.
I proved this in a Khan Academy
video, but the general
idea is if I have log base a
of b, that this is equal to
log base 10 of b divided
by log base 10 of a.
Actually, these both don't
have to be 10.
They just have to be
the same base.
10 tends to be convenient.
The other base that tends
to be convenient is e.
But anyway, let's use
that property
to solve this problem.
So log base 6 of 40 is equal to
log base 10 of 40 divided
by log base 10 of 6,
which is choice D.
All right, next problem.
Copy and paste it.
Just so you know, I don't like
talking while I'm copying and
pasting, because I think it
slows my computer down and
then I start sounding
like Optimus Prime.
All right, Jonathan wrote the
equation log base 6 of x minus
4 is equal to 0 on the board.
He needs one clue for
problem solving.
Which fact provides the correct
information that he
needs to solve the equation?
Well, I don't know if he
needs any information.
This statement is essentially
saying that 6 to the 0th power
is equal to x minus 4.
Then you could add 4 to both
sides, and you would get 6 to
the 0th power plus
4 is equal to x.
I guess if he didn't know the
definition already of 6 to the
0th power, he would have to
know that to know that it
equals 1, so 1 plus 4 is
equal to x, which is 5.
So I guess he has to know that
6 to the 0th power is a piece
of information.
Well this one wouldn't
have been useful.
6 to the first power, that's
not even useful even if you
didn't know it.
4 minus 4 isn't useful even
if you didn't know if.
But 6 minus 4, even
that's not useful.
Yes, choice A, he had
to know 6 to the 0th
power is equal to 1.
All right.
Let's see, they have
a couple more.
I'm going to copy and paste all
of them at the same time.
I'm getting bold.
All right, like that.
Let me clear all of this: clear
image, image, invert
colors, and I'm back
in business.
There you go.
All right, I never know
whether I should use a
dark-colored or light-colored
marker, because over here, the
light-colored ones look good,
but on the white, the darks.
So who knows?
Magenta tends to be good,
maybe purple.
What is the value of
log base 3 of 27?
So that's just asking 3 to what
power is equal to 27?
3 to the first is 3.
3 squared is 9.
3 to the third power
is equal to 27.
So log base 3 of 27
is equal to 3.
They, I guess, just want you to
know what the definition of
a logarithm is in
that question.
I'm noticing that there isn't
necessarily a progression of
difficulty in the problem.
They kind of flip between an
easy one and a hard one.
Who knows?
They're just a grab
bag of questions.
If log base 2-- no,
not log base 2.
They're saying log of 2 is
approximately equal to 0.301.
When people just write a log
without a base, you usually
assume it's base 10.
It's kind of like what you'd
get in your calculator.
If you just press log on your
calculator, it's log base 10.
So 10 to the 0.3 power
is equal to 2.
If log base 10 of 2 is
approximately equal to 0.301,
and log base 10 of 3 is
approximately equal to 0.477,
what is the approximate
value of log of 72?
So let's see, I think we just
have to do some prime
factorization here.
So 72, that's equal to the log--
let's think about it.
That's the log of-- let
me think about it.
This is 36 times 2.
Well, I don't know if
that even helps us.
3 to the third, that's 27.
This is 9 times 8.
So this is log of 3 to
the third times 2
squared; is that right?
So this is log of 9.
I made a mistake.
Ignore that.
So this is the same thing as
the logarithm of 9 times 8.
Fair enough.
So that's the same thing
as the log of 9
plus the log of 8.
Fair enough.
Well, that's the same thing as
the log of 3 squared plus the
log of 2 to the third.
2 to the third is equal to 8.
Let's keep going.
I think you see where
it's going.
3 squared is 9.
OK, so log of 3 squared, that's
the same thing as 2
times the log of 3.
The log of 2 to the third power,
that's the same thing
as 3 times the log of 2.
We know what the log of 3 is and
we know the log of 2 is.
The log of 3 is 0.477, so we
have 2 times 0.477 plus 3
times the log of 2, plus
3 times 0.301.
So 2 times 0.477-- let
me do it here.
So 0.477 times 2.
2 times 7 is 14 plus 1 is 15.
2 times 4 is 8 plus 1 is 9,
three numbers behind the
decimal point, 0.954.
Then 3 times point 0.301,
that's easier.
That's 0.903.
If you add them together, I
can already tell you, it's
going to be that right there.
It's going to be 1.857.
It's choice D.
Problem 58.
If x is a real number, for
what values of x is the
equation 3x minus 9 over 3 is
equal to x minus 3 true?
All right.
Well, if x is a real
number, let's just
play around with it.
Maybe it's just a truism.
Well, I know it is a truism.
Look at it.
Let me write it.
3x minus 9 over 3 is
equal to x minus 3.
Let's multiply both sides
of this equation by 3.
You'll get 3x minus 9 is
equal to 3x minus 9.
So we can stop there.
So if I take 3 times a number
and subtract 9 from it and if
I said that's the same thing as
taking 3 times a number and
subtracting 9 from it, well,
then x could be any number.
So it works for all
values of x.
You can keep solving.
Let's just add 9
to both sides.
You get 3x equal to 3x.
Divide both sides by 3, you
get x is equal to x.
Well, that's true for
any real number x.
It's equal to itself.
So that works for
all numbers x.
Let's see what else they
have to throw at us.
All right, let's do one more.
I've copied, and now
I have pasted.
On a recent test, Jeremy wrote
the equation x squared minus
16 divided by x minus 4
is equal to x plus 4.
Which of the following
statements is correct about
the equation he wrote?
So let's play with it a little
bit. x squared minus 16 over x
minus 4 is equal to x plus 4.
So immediately when you see
something like this, in order
to do this, what he had to say
is that x squared minus 16 is
x plus 4 times x minus 4.
That's over x minus 4.
Then to simplify from this to
that, he essentially canceled
out both of these things.
That's fine.
That's fine, assuming
that this number
down here is non-zero.
0 over 0 is undefined.
Anything over a 0
is undefined.
His simplification is true as
long as x does not equal 4.
Because if x equaled 4, then you
would have an 8 times a 0
divided by a 0, and 8 times
a 0 divided by a 0 is not
defined, so this doesn't work
when x is equal to 4.
If you think about it, if I were
to graph this equation or
his original equation, it
would look just like the
equation of x plus 4, except
it would have a hole at 4
because it's not defined
at x is equal to 4.
So they're not exactly
the same.
The graphs would be exactly the
same except at the point x
is equal 4.
So the point is b.
All right.
I'm out of time.
See you in the next video.